I'm a little fun a black where they
hardly make it I'll play with little
kids when I'm teaching so if you got a
potty mouth from a [ __ ] bag rapper Drake
with the rulers new album thank you for
choosing GTL has some of the most
graphic and lyrically interesting
wordplay you'll hear in a 20/20 rap
album how you getting soap I think
you're the police pitchfork called the
album mesmerizing and the Washington
Post called it the most urgent rap album
of the year what's most astonishing
about thank you for choosing GTL is that
it was recorded entirely from a prison
telephone in Los Angeles thank you for
using GTL the criminal justice reform in
the spotlight Draco's new album may help
bring attention to the story of how he
ended up in prison in the first place at
his first trial prosecutors used Draco's
lyrics and videos as evidence that he
had committed a 2016 murder at an LA
party I think many people have find it
difficult to imagine that these young
men are doing something complex
sophisticated that could be considered
literary artistic Eric Nielsen is the
co-author of rap on trial which
chronicles the growing phenomena of
criminal prosecutors using hip-hop music
as evidence I think many of them
understand that they are misrepresenting
rap lyrics they're doing it because they
want the jury to see this stuff that is
yep salacious it's profane and therefore
you're compromising somebody's right to
a fair trial one video that was used
featured Draco whose real name is
Darrell called wealth rapping and
dancing with his crew while holding guns
and wearing monkey masks oh my just lows
of what you find is deadly at a real
booth during his trial Caldwell
maintained he had never been in a gang
and that his lyrics were art not meant
to be taken literally the jury wasn't
convinced and convicted Caldwell on only
one count of illegal gun possession
Ellis District Attorney refiled charges
on criminal gang conspiracy and shooting
from a vehicle because of California's
harsh gang laws he could face life in
prison
Drako talks about this experience in one
of his new songs because phone calls
from prison are recorded Caldwell refers
to the fact that law enforcement is on
the line
any of that misconstrue if you're going
to use my music interview I accept you
use it the same way that your it is all
being reported country music
punk rock tree rap the same way that
you're gonna treat any other general
you're now gonna owe Denzel Washington
accountable for his role in training day
so don't do the same thing with my music
now is the time to plot plan strategize
organize and mobilize it is time to beat
up prosecutors you don't like it the
voting booth Nielsen has worked with a
rapper killer Mike on the issue
collaborating on an amicus brief
submitted to the Supreme Court in the
midst of recent police reform protests
killer Mike has made prosecutors
partially a point of his activism as
prosecutors become bolder in the ways
and strategies that they're using to put
artists rap artists in in jail I do
think that we are reaching a point at
which many people are going to have to
weigh their desire to engage in this art
form you know to master this art form
they're gonna have to weigh that with
the reality that it could get them in
trouble as these cases continue to grow
in number I do think that that is that
is absolutely possible myself but it's
fictional I love them imagination gives
to you I'm a real [ __ ] you